he nicknamed
wow all right welcome everybody we were
just notified that a verdict has been
reached in the gelane maxwell trial
and it has just broken that she is
indeed guilty um
a lot of the news has not even caught up
to this yet but we do have one report
from the new york post jury reaches
verdict in gilain maxwell sex
trafficking trial
and it is
um now wait a second this says
drudge says guilty but i don't actually
see that contained here
this is all breaking news literally
right now
but the article doesn't actually say
guilty
uh so we are all learning about what's
going on i'm being told guilty five out
of six counts she is indeed guilty
according to the independent live blog
independent live blog
let's see what they have
live blog elements
we are monitoring all of it extremely
closely okay not seeing that here
uh
let's wait until we know everything for
sure
elaine maxwell guilty on five of six
charges okay and we're expecting to see
this news come in as it goes cbsn not
yet covering it nbc news not yet
covering it but there it is on abc news
guilty indeed and presumably soon
cnn will have specifics on it
live updates
14 minutes ago this this is this is all
breaking quite literally right now but
the news we are getting is elaine
maxwell guilty
whoa the lies from the loony sphere oh
my god we don't want that uh breaking
guilty on five of six charges which is
quite remarkable if that is indeed the
case
uh msnbc has it okay let's find msnbc
live
here we go msnbc live
and i think we'll probably have to allow
ads
and refresh there
we have a 10 minute preview then i can
get logged in though so it shouldn't
shouldn't be a big deal
uh currently an ad playing a lot of
toxicity on this website that's for sure
uh daily beast says guilty bbc says
guilty etc etc all right so we're gonna
get all the information very very soon
uh
guilty on five of six
harry reid coverage happening here
uh okay we're going to get all of it
we're going to get all of it
there it is okay of the justice
department to take on sex trafficking
which can be a tough crime for state
prosecutors to attack because by its
very nature it often involves interstate
travel and that makes it difficult for a
prosecutor in one state to go after all
the aspects of these groups that are
involved in it it really requires
federal involvement wow these are
difficult cases to bring these
prosecutors plowed through a lot of
criticism early on in the case where
there was a lot of criticism of their
early witnesses as being unprepared or
not compelling and so getting this
verdict is a vindication for both these
victims but also for the the larger work
in this area of prosecuting trafficking
you know some of the victims
courageously um spoke out in in in a few
interviews and i wonder if you can
speak to
um how a jury sort of perceives that
testimony again it was graphic it was
upsetting it was painful the um jeffrey
epstein um the sordid nature of his
conduct and his abuse was um something
covered by journalists nationally and
obviously locally for a long time but
talk about what these witnesses went
through and how sort of re-traumatizing
it likely was for them
because society stigmatizes people who
have been victims of trafficking just
like victims in rape cases were
stigmatized and still are to some extent
for many years
these are some of the most difficult
crimes for victims all right so i'm told
that there even though the the entire
thing was not televised that we may soon
actually get video from the verdict
uh in the trial uh potentially
momentarily so we're going to stand by
for that i do want to say thank you to
iklassa woodburn who just signed up on
my website joinedpakman.com
this is potentially the last stream of
the year and it's great to have people
here although uh under
complex circumstances i guess we would
say although um we we could argue that
justice is being served here uh although
can you really make up for all of the
damage that was done by this individual
um over on twitch i do want to say
thanks to astrolycos sheldon black
badness try eye gamer
hentai lover poorly wiped oh no
that's a one two three four five got it
uh five putting us at six
um a number of different streams are
covering this let's listen to abc she
turned 60 in jail christmas day and now
she is going to be uh headed off to
prison potentially for the next 65 years
in all likelihood she will face far less
than that no sentencing date was
immediately set
it was impossible to read her expression
because glenn maxwell like everyone else
in that courtroom or a mask but she was
with her attorneys
her siblings two sisters and a brother
were seated in the gallery behind her
this verdict was undoubtedly
disappointing the defense said it needed
some time to get itself together before
it decided on any kind of an appeal they
also revealed that she has not had her
booster shot yet and due to the rapid
spread of the coronavirus they wanted to
get glenn maxwell boosted before they
brought her back into court for any kind
of sentencing yeah they don't want her
exposed to crova you have been following
this case as closely as anyone else over
the course of the last three days the
jury had been asking questions asking to
have testimony read back even today from
the pilot of jeffrey epstein's plane
tell us a bit about what they asked for
and what that meant to you leading up to
this verdict
the jury was incredibly thorough they
asked for more than a third of the case
they asked for the the transcripts of
testimony by 13 of the witnesses a third
of the case and so they they went
meticulously through all of the the
testimony of the accusers and then a
number of the supporting characters plus
a couple of the witnesses called by the
defense including a defense expert who
testified about the frailty of memory
that was part of the crux of the defense
case was that the the whole case against
glenn maxwell the defense said what was
based on on made-up stories and the
false memories of these accusers the
pronunciation galen i've never heard
that before
the women who testified including a
woman jane identified under a pseudonym
who said that she met galen maxwell and
jeffrey epstein when she was 14 years
old beginning years of abuse
now aaron you mentioned jane
count two
which she was not found guilty on is
enticement uh of a minor to travel to
engage in illegal sex acts can you tell
us a little bit more about that that
deals with jane right it does the the
first four counts only uh really dealt
with with jane's testimony and it
appears based on one of the questions
that the jury asked that the jurors were
confused by the charge by all the
elements that the government needed to
prove in order to to find her guilty of
enticing jane to travel when she was
under the age of 17
for the the purpose of having her engage
in illicit sexual activity with jeffrey
epstein the the jury at one point asked
for a definition of enticement and the
judge declined to give one beyond
referring the jury back to her legal
instructions that
the jurors were given before they began
deliberations and and it sounded to the
defense like the the jury was quite
confused about that charge and they
asked for all sorts of clarifications
the judge didn't do it and in the end uh
glenn maxwell was acquitted of count two
but that was a relatively minor charge
that exposed her to only five years in
prison the the the more significant
counts she was convicted of ck you are a
trial attorney for president in the
national bar association i'm curious you
heard aaron just describe how uh
meticulous the jury was in their
deliberation
i'm still reading we
we may get something from the court
although it doesn't it doesn't really
make sense that there would be video of
this because cameras were not allowed in
that's why we have the drawings
um and and of course the question is is
this just the start of people being
brought to justice
related to the exploits of jeffrey
epstein and uh we know trump's name has
been thrown around we know bill
clinton's name has been jones thrown
around prince andrew etc so we're going
to stand by to see if we get more
information on that i do want to say
thanks to deeper shades of house
dominator dido wiley gilbert and junk
saint for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 10.
um we are uh targeting
the number 100 today if we get to 100
website members and twitch subscribers i
will stream tomorrow
and potentially even on a new year's eve
stream which would really be something
else it's never happened before
uh never ever ever has happened before
and remember that any full-price
memberships yearly memberships between
now and new year's eve you can get a
free t-shirt if you would like big if
true and it is true big if true and it
is absolutely true um so we're going to
continue standing by for that and in the
mean let's listen to this i'm going to
see
if we have any other video from outside
the courtroom etc they have received
their charge criminal defense attorney
and former homicide prosecutor bernardo
villalona
joins us often to talk through these
cases and bernardo you and i have spoken
about this case before uh here on abc
news live i'm curious for your reaction
to this guilty on five of the six counts
as aaron pointed out count two was
relatively minor not for what it stood
for but relatively minor in the years
that she could face
is this just a flat out win for the
prosecution
absolutely this is a i would say a 100
percent went for the prosecution because
given
maxwell's age and also the accounts that
she faces
thanks for being with us here we go we
are outside the courtroom expecting all
sorts of different legal and non-legal
elements of the trial to speak shortly
a five of six counts convicted
and we don't yet know uh
what the sentence is going to be and it
could be it could be substantial
um i wanted i do want to say thanks to
kismar for gifting five subscriptions
via twitch putting us at 15. really
appreciate that um and remember that you
can sign up on my website joinpakman.com
with the coupon code obama obama
um
wow
an incredible incredible day all of a
sudden from jurors asking to review so
much of the evidence to the announcement
that a verdict has been reached to the
announcement of the verdict five of six
counts guilty not guilty on the
enticement count that's the one that
they were not
uh convinced of the jury that is
and um we are going to be hearing maybe
from defense attorneys maybe from
prosecutors maybe from both momentarily
um cameras trained on the courthouse and
uh
quite quite literally anything could
happen
i did have a few other things
that i wanted to go over as we wait
um
let me see here
oh
someone made some sort of deep fakes of
our regular caller whitney
tell me if you fi if you guys find this
interesting that this is it's sort of
clever
not bit rex that's not what we want here
we go
because they've been so amped up
by their race card
that they think all they have to say is
wow
because they know that other people just
want
their side of the argument to be right
even though they're wrong
that's one possible interpretation of
whitney
uh here's a here's another one and he
had to make a point of being like
you know with this kind of a thing
like we want to make sure to deal with
it correctly and not blame
the person the place the country
where
uh so that's the second interpretation
here's the third oh that um red hair
originated in the middle east where
there's like muslim
um
religions prominence over there
and it's not in egypt any justice
they've changed to christianity right
and then here's your final whitney
interpretation
being like oh we're just using the men
for money and just between you you're in
their brains with freaking medication
because they have a mental illness i
think three is the best i'm going with
three
and also mutilating children
oof
okay
um so that is that uh you know you be
the judge of what it
signifies or what it means i do have a
quiz we're gonna be taking
uh one of my colleagues john sent this
to me and said it might be a good stream
element and i think it is it's called
2020 or 2021. you know we've experienced
such some people call it time
compression some call it time expansion
others call it time dilation during the
pandemic this is a quiz called 2020 or
2021 where i will see if i can identify
correctly whether certain events took
place this year or last year as we close
out the year
here we are standing by at the
courthouse
in uh i believe in new york city
um awaiting we don't even know who we're
going to hear from we just we just don't
know yet uh but give five of six guilty
verdicts in the gilain maxwell trial
and an extraordinary situation i want to
say thanks to cappy b
for the twitch prime subscription you're
number 16 today thank you very much i
really do appreciate that
we are closing out the year this may be
the last stream we may have one more
stream
we may have two more streams we don't
really know yet
um it's sort of up uh up to you guys
but i can't tell you how much i
appreciate everybody who stopped by
millions of people have stopped by our
streams in 2021
and hopefully just as many if not more
in 2022 we're really kind of revving up
for what may be a big
midterm
uh the 2018 midterms garnered more
interest than any other midterms since
i've been in this business
and
it's conceivable because of what's at
stake in 2022
that uh
2022 may even be bigger
uh as far as midterms go we just don't
know yet we just don't know yet
but extraordinary extraordinary
circumstances
uh let's listen and see what's going on
pilate uh his housekeeper uh and the
like and so right now uh you can see
that we have multiple uh vantage points
at the moment where we are
just kind of get a sense
of what is happening outside
of the courthouse there in lower
manhattan uh and so
we're going to try again with former
federal prosecutor doug burns who's been
throughout the duration of this
following alongside us offering some
really so if you're just joining us the
verdict is guilty on five of six counts
guilty on five of six counts for jilan
maxwell the only not guilty verdict was
one of enticement
uh
for traveling across state lines let me
actually get the specifics here
uh okay
so
actually not finding the count by count
let's see if we have ah here it is okay
so not guilty on enticement of a minor
to travel to engage in illegal sex acts
guilty on everything else which includes
conspiracy to incite minors to entice
minors
to travel now that's weird
oh guilty of conspiracy okay so i guess
guilty as part of the conspiracy to do
it but not individually guilty of that
guilty on conspiracy to transport minors
with intent to engage in criminal sex
acts guilty of transporting a minor with
intent to engage in criminal sexual
activity guilty of a sex trafficking
conspiracy and guilty of the sex
trafficking of a minor so um
seemingly overlapping
charges in many ways but legally
distinct
in ways that are um relevant
relevant as we stand by here outside the
courthouse
super chats are starting to come in
although they are not on screen i can
still see them wendy says very happy to
see jillaine maxwell found guilty that's
wendy from canada
nemo nova
says hello sir thanks for all that you
do thank you nemo appreciate that great
to see you here
um i think that's all i've got
in terms of super chats today
thanks to zambarilla for the twitch
prime subscription coming with the
message i've enjoyed your streams
strongly thank you so much i really
appreciate that
and uh and you being here
daniel says sir your 2021 stream count
is up in the air right
uh wait where do i have that i don't
even know what i'm doing sir no wait sir
your wife is up in the air exactly
uh very very much appreciate that
um questions being asked in the chat
about who's next in all of this we we
just don't know
we just don't know
uh at this point in time
a lot of people confused saying i used
obama but it's not costing sixty dollars
so let me
i'm gonna only do this once and if
there's still confusion after this
it's out of my it's above my pay grade
okay
if you want a free t-shirt with your
membership
okay
you got to pay full price for a year
that means at least 60
full price one year you get a membership
you email info davidpakman.com and say
give me the free t-shirt
the coupon code obama obama
saves you an insane amount so it's like
a dollar eighty a month or 18 bucks for
the year
you can take the discount but you don't
get the free t-shirt it's not a deal for
us to lose money on memberships it
doesn't make any sense it just doesn't
make sense to lose money on memberships
okay so use the coupon code
if you want but that's not the free
t-shirt it's one or the other and all of
this stuff is at joinpackman.com
we are trying to close out the year
strongly uh oh what's going on here
so again you know they were
prognosticators
in all directions saying there were only
four why weren't there more but i told
you i'm not patting myself on the back
for my crystal ball skills but i told
you that i expected a conviction and i
was not surprised enough that i entered
okay
doug let's talk about the fact that she
didn't take the stand in her own defense
uh vile audio i mean just absolutely
vile vile audio
uh let's see if anyone else is waiting
at the courthouse at this point
uh
doesn't seem like it this is really our
courthouse stream any minute now any
minute now
they should be here i am curious whether
court tv
also has coverage let's just take a
quick look
see what they've got going on
uh they will be right back
let's cue that up just so that we have
it and i think i still have
uh yeah okay
okay good so that we'll actually keep
that going there
what if the news let you see
here and think for yourself we are at
the absolute dawn of this of seeing
where this goes introducing a new point
of view yours
newsy watch free we'll keep an eye on
that
uh but standing by right now at the
courthouse other messages that are
coming in from people
um the s r cronin says via super chat on
youtube david keep up the great work
thank you ethan says are you taking
calls
uh
i don't know i don't know about that i
mean maybe if we got to 100 members luis
says we're really starting 2022 with
maxwell didn't kill herself
let's not get ahead of ourselves okay
let's not get ahead of ourselves here
uh
that's not uh you know
let's just take it easy on that
uh i'm gonna be really careful in how i
pronounce this
because okay i don't even know if i can
say it
i appreciate the twitch prime
subscription don't want to get myself
banned off of twitch so i'm going to be
very very careful with that one
extremely extremely careful uh we don't
want to have a have a problem here
um
still monitoring court tv yeah any i i'm
reading we're expecting to hear from
both
defense and prosecution although you
know how quickly these things can change
i don't really
i don't really know that that may or may
not happen
um
ethan says the new matrix is a
documentary bro i haven't seen it yet
i have not seen the new matrix but
always interested i'm actually in the
middle of watching uh don't look up
right now written by david pakman show
guest david sirota friend of the show
he's been on the show it's gotta be two
or three times maybe david sirota
writing the film about 40 of the way
through it uh right now i'm told the
second half is not as good and i'm
already seeing it softening a little bit
about 40 in but uh leo dicaprio's good
and you know other people other people
in it are great
um but i'll give a full review once i'm
um once i've seen the entire thing once
i've seen the entire thing
uh okay
see what's happening i'm as dumb as that
sounds so you and i say let's rob a bank
tomorrow andrew you agree with me i say
here's the implement we're going to use
i hand it to you that's an overt act we
then don't rob the bank we can be guilty
of conspiracy i know that gets a little
complicated so what we had here is
preparing yet conspiracy to do something
and then doing it conspiracy doing it
conspiracy doing three pairs now
the conspiracy casts carry a five-year
cap
because doing a conspiracy to do another
crime has its own five-year limitation
that's the good news for her the bad
news is the underlying two that she got
convicted of carry much much more
exposure than five years so a quick
glance by me
maybe last week of the united states
sentencing guidelines book um shows me
that no you're talking about very very
significant prison time i have no
hesitancy in just giving a ballpark uh
sort of conceptual approximation
she's looking at around 12 to 15 years
andrew
okay and of course uh doug and we had
been speaking you know she has been held
in custody for the duration of this
trial i believe since july
of 2020 uh the judge uh i believe did
not grant her bail citing her uh as a
flight risk and so she has been
in custody for the duration of this uh
she appeared in court today uh as the
jury i mean between time served and uh
this is not federal right so she could
get time off for good behavior
it might not be that much more right
powerful influential men that uh you
know he
commiserated and
cavorted with throughout the duration of
his uh escapades and she was along side
him all right we're standing by bop it
says via super chat so glad maxwell is
being held accountable thanks for
covering this my pleasure
um
what what's happening here on court tv a
lot of time in wisconsin they're not
covering it okay so we'll stay over here
at the courthouse um will i make a
gilain related coupon code i would use
it yeah i guess so i guess so let's
let's try that now here here will be the
trick i'm going to make the coupon code
just shilane
but you have to spell it correctly and
i'm not going to spell it for you okay
so if you want to take advantage of a
new coupon code
big discount big big discount to close
out the year the coupon code is g lane
at joinpakman.com you have to spell it
correctly first person to use it can
also get a free item from my online
store
i do want to say thanks to
sitlali rios who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code obama obama
and his new member number 19
also thanks to the human google and
symbolic gamer for the twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 20 and 21. i'm
actually i i i hope this isn't a joke or
rather i hope it is a joke i'm seeing
people's coupon codes rejected because
they are misspelling gilain
it's on the screen guys
it's on the screen i i don't know what
else i can do
uh
wow
wow
it's it's just the it's just elaine
that's all it is
there's no it's not it's not a big
it's not a big thing
um
man that's
it's depressing me a little bit unless
it's really subtle trolling ethan says
he's running for u.s house in kentucky
all right very good luck
one and only smith he says great show
good to see you working with farren
cousins learned a lot from your show
thank you
very much appreciate that
um
denver says hey david thanks for the
excellent cameo you did for me it was
the best birthday surprise i could have
asked for yeah the cameos have been on
fire lately it's crazy
jerry says glad she was found guilty
however if the men aren't indicted it's
just the same old same old well the main
guy is dead so now it's a question of
who where what is their evidence for
when it comes to other people uh is
there actually anything on
uh trump is there anything on clinton or
you know it's not it's not clear to me
i want to say thank you to robert
vazquez the first person today to use
the coupon code gilain and as a result
robert qualifies for a free item from
the david pakman show store also thanks
to edwin goswick who just paid full
price for a membership at
joinpackman.com
always appreciate that
um once we're done with this i am going
to do the
undo an ad ad blocker here
okay i am gonna do this 20 or 21 quiz
we're going to do that a little later i
think that that'll be pretty interesting
um but first we are standing by for
statements here
uh outside the courthouse
i am very curious to see who we hear
from and what they have to say very very
curious uh thank you to ross dewer
for signing up at joinedpakman.com with
the coupon code obama
number 24 today very very much
appreciate that
um
i
this should be any any moment now
as the press conference is building dark
on the east coast of course because it
is
december
um
sun's setting very very early
what are what is this what are people
doing are there people that need to get
banned here i will ban people if we need
to these would be the bail argument as
well
and during the bail argument they can
make the point about how strong the case
is and if the judge feels it's a strong
case and knows that there's a 10-year
potential
mandatory minimum involved then the
judge knows that she's going to get time
served etc now had she been acquitted
hypothetically in the law school
classroom then you turn around and say
wow i get to serve all that time even if
i'm not guilty but that's now completely
academic to your point but you will
jason says how do you expect us to spell
her name correctly when you yourself
have pronounced it seven different ways
during this segment well listen there's
one spelling and there's many
pronunciations i've already heard
everything from galen
to zeelane jizzlane
jalen
jillaine
yeah but there is only one spelling
there's only one spelling tr says via
super chat shout out to mike lehmann all
right
i hope that's not like a horrible racist
or anything
um thanks to five port studios for the
twitch prime sub says keep the content
coming david hope you're taking a day
off tomorrow to relax we're actually on
tomorrow we've got a new show tomorrow
uh but no new show friday if there's
anything friday it would be a casual
absolute final new year's eve live
stream
uh but i thank you for the twitch prime
subscription you're number 25 today very
very exciting
some people are saying it's gelane not
jilane
listen i don't know what it is i know
she's guilty on five of six counts
that's what we know so far
okay that's that we can be sure of
um
it still looks like this is really our
only
live stream outside the courthouse
activity is building
maybe just a few more minutes
maybe just a few more minutes here
a lot of activity at the courthouse
elaine maxwell
it is a federal case it is a federal
case and my understanding is that in
federal cases there is no time off for
good behavior uh our legal
analysts
can confirm or deny
bbc live i'm told has live coverage
let's take a look at that
um
i don't even know where i don't even
know what what bbc live is like is that
on their website
see live is it live on youtube
uh i don't even know that we need it i
mean we're live here at the courthouse
yeah i don't even know where that is
yeah it doesn't matter we we've got
we're this is if anything's going to
happen it's going to happen here denver
says david sir will you be kissing
stream chat at midnight on
new year's something to look at yeah i
think we need to look at that pretty
strongly looking at that very strongly
one of the wettest we've ever seen from
the standpoint of water exactly no
that's that's a that's a crucial issue
it's a critical issue
gail says people are getting swayed by
dr john campbell videos on ivermectin
vaccine side effects is depressing
because he's misrepresenting data will
you cover it yeah you know i it's just
like
can can we just remember
that dr john campbell is not a medical
doctor
he does a lot of good coverage i think
that some of the stuff on vaccines and
ivermectin has not been so good but he
does some good stuff but but but you
know when we talk about this whole thing
where everybody's so quick to say anyone
who's not a medical doctor you have to
remember
dr john campbell is talking about
medicine and he's not a medical doctor
it's just important to remember that
because they want to they they
constantly want to remind us of that
uh when it comes to anybody else you
know that it's it's not like a huge
big thing
you know i casually will watch his
videos and there's some good information
presented i want to say thanks to asf
clops for the twitch prime subscription
number 26 today
who says sir if trump had done the right
thing two years ago by responsibly
handling the virus and telling the truth
he could very well be our president
right now i can i think if trump had
handled the virus well
he would have won i think there's no
doubt whatsoever
thanks also to k dobbs and kismar for
the twitch prime subscriptions putting
us at 28 today
okay i i'm still seeing the confusion
if you use
the discount code gillane
you get a discount but not the free
t-shirt we can't lose money on the
memberships we try to make money with
the memberships
if you just want to get a free t-shirt
pay full price for the year it's 60
bucks
it's
i mean
i just don't know how else to explain it
thanks to serenader for the twitch prime
subscription you're number 29 today
um
geez it's like
i don't know how else to explain it
are you concerned about hyperinflation
and empty shelves don't know if you're
still living in the u.s but it's bad
i am not concerned about hyperinflation
and empty shelves at this point in time
if i become concerned i will tell you
ryan nowicki says via super chat given
cia and other agencies can choose not to
prosecute child sex crimes to save face
what do you see is the most reasonable
way to address that well they can still
be pr ci
the cia prosecutes i don't even know
what that means ryan i'm gonna have to
look into that a little more
not totally sure i know what that means
um
john campbell has a phd in magical
medical education and is a nurse
yes
meaning he's not a medical doctor it's
not an attack
it's just a statement of fact
he's just not a medical doctor that
doesn't mean any particular piece of
information is accurate or not accurate
you either are a medical doctor or
you're not it's guys everybody's please
relax guys
please relax
thanks to ecotis the teal appeal and nmh
freak
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 30 31 and 32.
also thanks to skittlestu for gifting a
subscription and putting us at 33.
uh
okay let's listen held accountable for
her crimes this office will always stand
with victims we'll always follow the
facts wherever they lead and will always
fight to ensure that no one no matter
how powerful and well connected
is above the law that's a statement
coming in from the southern district of
new york u.s attorney damian williams in
reaction
to the verdict here and of course um
and doug i want to get your uh kind of
reaction to this uh so if if sdny is
putting out a statement
then maybe they're not going to speak
and we're just going to hear from the
defense attorneys there are more
important more people coming out of this
front door now
um
so hopefully that will be very very soon
it's it's a real question mark as to
what's going on
but uh
anything could be going on inside there
do i have voicemails i do let's just
listen to a few voicemails while we wait
here
uh let's see what we got
hey david hey producer pat i heard you
guys talking on the bonus show this is
daryl from connecticut i just wanted to
give you a little insight on the fuel
gauge staying at full
um
why okay so for people who don't know
this
i delivered
a hysterical rant about fuel gauges on a
bonus show on monday because when i was
away recently i rented an uh what we
call an ice vehicle an internal
combustion engine vehicle we in the
electric vehicle community call them ice
cars
and i had forgotten about how the fuel
gauge when you fill up
it's like wow it's so full and you drive
and drive and drive and it's still full
and you start thinking i'm gonna be able
to drive a month on one tank and then
the decline is so fast that i was
wondering not alleging wrongdoing by the
manufacturers making it deliberately
deceptive i was just saying
um
maybe there's something about i don't
know if it's a floater that's measuring
the fuel or what maybe there's something
about it technically that explains why
that happens i think we're about to hear
why that is a mechanical limitation most
fuel gauges use a float
and floats don't respond well in a
vehicle's fuel tank where the fuel level
is shifting left to right as the angle
of the vehicle changes there you go
backwards and so forth so they use a
float on an arm so just like your hand
on the end of your arm when you're up at
the top and it's near vertical or
perpendicular to the parallel to the
ground
as you lower your arm
there's an arc that takes place so the
the increased fall off is after you get
from the top where the fuel
float is sitting level at a full tank
it takes in a while it drops very slowly
until you start getting on the arc
radius and then it drops off quicker
oh and then we lose them
so that's the explanation
that's the explanation
um some people saying it's better in
well-designed cars
okay i mean this
i've driven all sorts of different cars
and the same thing seems to happen but
it's an explanation
and that's great we got an explanation
for the uh for the question
uh
okay see what's happening here mexico
manhattan and the virgin islands the
lifestyle was just off the charts and
people are fascinated and somewhat
deteriorated by it when the history
books are written about the case okay so
we're still standing by let's see if
we've got any other
um
actually we've got a lot of voicemails
here coming in
a new voicemail looks like this is from
whitney
how come women don't get in trouble for
endorsing rape because i feel like it's
always like oh well
um
you know it was like rape culture
or
she endorsed like rape culture why is it
never like
oh well
you endorse rape in general why do they
call it like rape culture
it's like
whitney i don't know what you're talking
about here's another call
hey david my name is tyler from kansas
cold enough to view messages from me i
was actually just listening uh to the
video that you posted on youtube
um
basically where the republicans were
laying out their plan on how to steal
the election on january 6th i feel like
the issue that we're running into a lot
of times is that we're not getting the
smoking gun which is them basically
admitting
that they knew the whole time their
election fraud stuff was not real and
that they were just going to try to
steal the election anyway which it
almost kind of seems like we're kind of
tip toeing that line right now with the
green bay sweep stuff with steve bannon
where they're never really talking about
hey we had all this fraud and this is
why we're doing this stuff yeah we
actually talk about that on today's show
that that's that's quite an interesting
story uh okay thanks for the assist
someone recommending the independent
that they have a good uh good camera
shot here outside the courthouse
so much seems to be happening and
there's a whole it's like a nest of
microphones here so presumably this is
going to be uh all happening really
really soon
um
some confusion still about what twitch
prime is okay so twit
i believe that what the way to explain
twitch prime is
if you have an amazon prime account you
get a free twitch prime subscription
every month why because amazon owns
twitch
what that means is there's five bucks
you can take from bezos and give to
whoever you want you've got to link
amazon and twitch once you do that
there's a button that says free sub
ready if you're watching on desktop on
mobile i don't know exactly what it
looks like
um and you can get a you get a free
subscription to our show we get a couple
bucks
bezos loses a couple bucks and otherwise
it's all good okay that's what twitch
prime is i don't i just don't know how
else to explain it
uh that's that's quite simply what it is
um okay couple
more voicemails just as we wait here for
the press conference
let's see what else we've got
i don't wait no actually i don't want to
play them
this is an old one from the egg man
dave i'm sorry i have to pause your
friday show in the middle of these
interesting phone calls so i can watch
the written house verdict get ready how
do i watch you watch it i am so like
stupid with technology and stuff i can't
figure this stuff out
dave i want to be disappointed with you
equally at the same time it'll bond up
oh my god i'm gonna try to watch this
thing now dave it's on [ __ ] is gonna
happen in kenosha oh my god okay well
that this is all outdated now at this
point in time i'm going to try to we
i'm still working through so many old
voicemails i'm going to skip written
house stuff because it's just not the
topic right now this is written house
this is written house written house
written house
um
here's an old whitney voicemail
i found this um this article
in
the newspaper
whitney barely audible in this one
um
let's see what else we've got here
a lot of written this is still a lot of
old written house style stuff let me go
a little newer here
hey david
you know how you're always
like to share
with your listeners conspiracies
well i got one for you
you know how there's a form of
earthquakes going on
off the coast of oregon
and they're pretty big you know 3.5 5.8
and they're not your usual
swarm of earthquakes because they're
stronger than normal
well
those aren't natural quakes
i really think okay all right we're
moving on
um
let's see
what else we've got here
what is happening here why are they
filming this guy like who's this guy why
is that guy getting a film
hey david pacman how you doing
um
i'm curious if you know anything or
heard anything about macintosh computers
becoming bricked
b-r-i-c-k-e-d
wrecked no
um i don't even know how to use a
macintosh computer i don't know how to
use an iphone and i don't know how to
use a macintosh computer i've never had
either i don't know anything about them
like i i could tell you nothing nothing
nothing about them
mjr schneider says via super chat on
youtube i've noticed conspiracy theories
about the cia and fbi became
increasingly mainstream on the right
this year do you find this concerning
yeah i find it concerning along with a
ton of other things i mean
it's not particularly concerning but it
is a concern for sure
i want to say thanks to
mr jevious
himalayan salty
afro2go reviews fiddypat and andrew emf
for five more twitch prime subscriptions
thanks guys i really appreciate that uh
and if we we are 38 of the way to 100 we
will uh lock in another stream tomorrow
um if we get to 102 ways to do that you
can sign up at joinpakman.com one of the
coupon codes is
obama the other one is gillane or gelane
yeah you've got to know how to spell it
though
also twitch counts there
couple others let's see here
here's a newer eggman voicemail
hey you said you checked on the look the
legitimacy of the voice message you got
yesterday that old man that really hates
you that you thought was straight out of
central casting in la or something
how do you check on the legitimacy you
made sure he was real and wasn't fake
like you do with troy york dave my
question how many of your voice messages
you check on the legitimacy of have you
ever done that to me yes you've been
outside my house checking on me no we
don't have to go to your house if i'm
real
that was not your best new voice message
guy ever
i'm highly insulted at that
shalom brother wow
the eggman really shot out of a cannon
there really really shot out of a cannon
fat produce says what's your android
phone and brand of choice
i'm a samsung guy
i'm a sam samsung guy
uh call me crazy
yeah no i know no you guys are walking
yeah
no
it's a hat right yeah yeah that's a hat
oh my god no maybe it is her hair
oh my god i think it is her hair
actually that's funny i apologize
i thought it was one of those russian
hats
oh no it maybe it's her hair
it is a hat okay it's a hat it's a hat
you can see hair under it
i can't to be honest
her hair is brown
yeah i ca i honestly can't tell what
that is that's really interesting though
really really interesting
we should be very close to the start of
this thing
um i can't tell you how much i want to
thank one particular person and because
i want to do it i'm going to do it dan
mariano just signed up at
joinedpakman.com using the coupon code
obama obama and his new member number 39
today dan
you're killing it i can't thank you
enough
i also want to say thanks to the chick
for the atlantic zell geth and shiv
dragon for the twitch prime
subscriptions bumping us up to 43 at
this point in time
other super chats coming in
actually no no other super chats coming
in that's okay
it's okay
couple other voicemails here
um
let's see
and i don't even know what that's about
whatever you do make sure you go to the
bathroom somewhere other than the
carpool yeah
that was really weird i want to say
thank you to justin thunderberger as
well as esther
for the twitch prime subscriptions uh
pushing us very dangerously close to 50.
that was a really really strange
voicemail all right they are now
they are either running more audio now
or the thing has been cancelled and
they're taking them their microphones
and going home
see if we can figure out what it is
hard to tell here's another one of these
weird calls
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
woman
man that's that's very strange very very
strange
don't even know what to make of that
quite frankly
okay
we may be off
of these for the time being
see what this is what's up david love
the show especially the the battles that
you go through with the
your boy jesse peterson always always a
pleasure to
listen to you making sound like a fool
uh the reason i'm calling those
based on a video i just watched where
you know
one of your uh you know viewers is
asking about
uh jewish attendance at the christmas
party or whatever not quite the same
thing but uh you know i am a black man
i'll just get to the point i'm a black
man i was recently
told
that
i wasn't a viable uh dating partner not
a serious quote-unquote serious dating
partner uh because i wasn't jewish
i was just kind of
not really sure honestly how to feel
about that
um
i'm kind of hoping that you would
weigh in on it uh it doesn't quite make
sense to me it feels wrong to
you know discriminate against anyone for
any sort of immutable characteristic
like that yeah that's my view i don't
you know to me it just seems uh
i'm against such discrimination so i
don't know
i don't know what else to say about that
that's
that's my view you know it's been my
view uh
for a very very long time
let's see what else we've got here
we're still standing by here
mr pacman how are you doing today i
enjoy your show thank you i don't catch
them every time they come out
but
i watch them i just saw the one about
the evangelist preacher
dying
now eight months ago
i saw a program where this evangelist
was saying the virus was from god and he
was put on earth
to kill all the bad people and
hateful people and
all that
and then you got this evangelist saying
the vaccines are bad and they're no good
don't do it so if god put this virus on
earth to kill all these bad people
okay
here's the thought you got all these
talk show hosts dying
and all these preachers dying
so why did god put this vaccine on the
earth to kill all the bad people and all
these people are dying just a thought
okay that's very very interesting
hard to know how to even react to that
but it is interesting
i want to say thank you to gilgame
hair kev stargazer and 420 big tyrone
for the twitch prime subscriptions
because we're at 49
the next website member who would be
number 50
you also can get a free item from my
online store any t-shirt coffee mug
whatever you want sign up at
joinpacman.com even with the discount
and whoever is number 50 i will give you
a free item
um i kind of want to do the 20 20 21
quiz while we wait here
let's let's do it
yeah we'll hear if something happens
okay this is the end this is going to be
fun this is the nbc news
hindsight is 2020 or 2021. this is a
quiz
where i have to guess whether certain
events took place this year or last year
this whole pandemic has blended together
let's just jump right in
covet cases hit five million that's
gotta be twenty twenty
correct okay good
senate confirms amy kovet barrett that
was 20 20.
correct
chauvin sentenced that was this year
correct hold on are people seeing this
they are young
massive warehouse explosion rocks beirut
i think that was this year oh that was
2020. wow that felt like it was this
year
let's keep going
house of representatives impeaches trump
that was this year
condominium that was definitely this
year
chloe xiao makes history for nomad land
i don't even know who that is
i'll guess this here okay no i got it
right
boy scouts hobbled by sex abuse file for
bankruptcy
i think that was last year yeah
meghan markle and prince harry's
explosive oprah interview believe that
was this year
good
washington team retires its con long
condemned
indigenous slur nickname that was this
year oh no it was last year
jack dorsey steps down that was really
recent
three white men found guilty that was
definitely this year yep the arbory
thing
supreme court rules lgbt workers
that was last year
yeah
fda grants full approval that was this
year
chile legalizes same-sex marriage
that i have no idea
think last year no it was this year
okay let's just see okay we're still
standing by here
doge meme nft if it's nft it must be
this year right yeah okay
so far i've got 13 out of 16.
kim kardashian files for divorce from
kanye west i think that was this year
yep
hurricane laura
slams louisiana and texas at cap four
i always forget the names of these
i think that was this year
no it was last year wow
cuomo resigns that was this year okay
black panther star chadwick boseman dies
i think that was last year yeah
twitter suspends scrump
you know i don't remember was the trump
suspension
no it was it was within days of him
leaving office right yeah it was 20 21.
okay
facebook whistleblower tell us that was
this year yeah
coronavirus gets an official name from
the world health organization covid19
it's got to be last year
yeah
just keep an eye out here
uh-oh what happened
all right we'll get back to that
chaos erupts as a pro-trump mob okay
that was 1-6-21
delta accounts for 10 of cases 21.
bezos makes the flight yep 21.
yunkan wins that's 21.
trump has mild symptoms after testing
positive for kovid that was 20.
kovid kills a million around the world
i think that's this year oh wow a
million died by 2020 okay
well
crazy times
toxic toads collected by hand in taiwan
i have no idea i didn't even hear about
that story let's go with last year no
that was this year
giuliani suspended from practicing law
that was this year
texans wake up without safe drinking
water
hmm
after a winter storm
i think that was
oh no it was this year wow
trump sue's facebook that was this year
michelle wu wins that was this year
twitter suspends 50 white nationalist
accounts who knows uh i guess this year
no that was last year
obama announces the death of the former
first dog beau
i think that was this year
yep
chess business booming uh
is that last year i think this year no
that was last year
african-american spelling bee champ xyla
avant-garde makes history i believe that
was last year nope it was this year
nicki minaj says covet vaccine made
cousins friend impotent this year
last ten
fewer than half of americans say they'll
get a coveted vaccine i think that was
last year and this year the number went
up
okay we're still standing by
oregon prepares for mass fatality
incident aspires rage that was this past
summer right no it was last year
eddie van halen dead of cancer
eddie van gaal
i think this year now
it's falling apart
u.s reaches 500 000 deaths from covid
i think this year yeah
alex trebek died i believe that was this
year it was not
house passes infrastructure bill that
was this year
parasite becomes first foreign language
film i don't know anything about the
oscars i'll guess this year no that was
wrong
gabby petito disappears this year
facebook bans queuing on i think this
year nope that was last year
louisville reaches 12 million dollars
settlement man i have no idea on this
one
let's try this here no
judge rules on the mask man i think
that's this year
all right i got 34 out of 50.
see if you can do better than that guys
go and see if you can beat mice well
that we just went through all the
answers so because it doesn't really
matter
i want to say thank you to joshua carmen
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code obama
you're number 50 meaning you get a free
item from my online store
also want to say thanks to
the village idiot clever
alice maravius
and clever with a gift
putting us at 54 via twitch also thanks
to oceanova for re-upping a twitch
subscription for 22 months number 55.
does anybody know what's happening with
this press conference
it must be soon right
i want to say thanks to laura plourde
for the twit uh for the website
membership at joinedpakman.com number 56
thank you laura
[Music]
couple other new voicemails that just
came in let's listen
hey david i've been watching your videos
for a while typically on youtube i was
just watching your video and i've been
following the whole alex jones versus
donald trump thing my biggest question
with that is is why hasn't trump come
out more forcefully against alex jones
it seems like anybody for the last six
years that has ever attacked donald
trump whether it be republicans
themselves uh democrats people that have
left his administration
um and have written books and attacked
him like he's always attacked right back
at him
donald trump has not attacked alex jones
and i i'm curious as to why it kind of
seems like he's tiptoeing around him
used marjorie taylor green as a way to
put out kind of
the fire a little bit i just don't think
trump's uh quite frankly i don't think
trump's even paying attention to that
what's that noise what a strange noise
let's see what else we got here
david sir
uh why did you not take the voice calls
of my discord today
i was really looking forward to seeing
you there's no friday show this week
because it's uh we're taking it the
friday off in observance of new year's
day even though it's new year's eve so
there is no friday show we record calls
on wednesday for the friday show no need
to because there is no such
call hi david just so you know the
proper way to pronounce
uh miss uh maxwell's first name
is jizz lane as if it were spelled
j-i-z-z-l-a-n-e i know this first hand i
have been to the island not a pedal
though all i did was got a margarita
passed out and went home he's not a
pedoville what does that even mean a
pedoville i want to say thank you to
jay tandaway for gifting a sub on twitch
it's a bobbin pdx for the twitch prime
sub and ryder prime for the twitch prime
sub putting us at 59.
we must be really close to this press
conference right i mean it's like how
how long could this go on
um let's see if i've got some other
super chats here
daniel mcnamara says i just subbed via
twitch when the sub count was is 49 but
it still hasn't gone up to 50. okay well
now we're at 59 so hopefully we took
care of that for you
val mcclinchy via youtube says happy new
year david and everyone thanks to you
val very much appreciate it
and i think that's it as far as
chats go
news 4 nashville
has a better view
okay
let's see
i don't even see that they're live
yeah they're not even live according to
what i'm finding on their youtube
channel
uh yeah
so
that's unfortunate but
do i think marjorie taylor green is
actually crazy or pretending that came
in via super chat i think she's actually
crazy
um
yeah i think she's bonkers
how do i feel about no dislikes showing
on youtube anymore i don't care i never
looked at him anyway
it makes no difference to me at all
um
yeah it's
i a lot of people have been talking
about the removal of dislikes
and i even got some voicemails from
people saying david you turned off
dislikes
only on your channel i mean it's like no
you can't do that it was a youtube thing
but um
i just don't care yeah it makes no
difference i i was never looking at that
i want to say thanks to edward tran
edward tran just signed up using the
coupon code obama
on my website and his new member number
60 today thank you edward i really
appreciate that uh and your support
um
yeah i i don't know whether this press
conference is actually going to happen
dude there's there's one person still
holding a boom mic up in the air like
it's about to happen
let's see if court tv has anything on it
yeah
they don't
see if anybody else
very very strange i mean look let's wait
a little longer and see what happens
it's funny like do we need a different
stream or is this stream okay i don't
know why people are saying you should
you should watch a different stream it's
like this stream seems as good as any
uh
let's see what sky news has
let's take a look here
she said that jeffrey epstein crawled
into bed with her one morning and
pressed himself up against her she said
she was
traumatized
by that then
her attorney her lawyer
siegrid macaulay has released a
statement in the last few minutes on
behalf of annie farmer
i'll just read you that statement now
she says today's verdict is a tarot
towering victory
not just for the brave women who
testified in this trial but for the
women around the world whose young and
tender lives were diminished and damaged
by the abhorrent actions of gulen
maxwell for too long their voices were
ignored and discounted and their
characters disgraced but no more i'm in
all of their sacrifice their courage and
the strength that they have shown in
pursuit of justice today's verdict makes
clear that those who prey upon prey upon
and traffic miners are committing
serious crimes punishable under the law
glenn maxwell has been held accountable
and justice has been done guillen
maxwell
facing very possibly very probably the
rest of her life in prison after being
convicted of five of the six charges
against her including that most serious
sex trafficking charge which
has a tariff a maximum tariff of 40
years
in prison
prosecutors haven't said yet whether
they intend to try maxwell on two
remaining perjury counts against her um
on the defense's request they were
separated
from the six charges uh that were heard
in this trial we've also just just
received through a statement um from a
lawyer jack scarole
who represented another of the victims
who testified under only her first name
carolyn she she was the
woman then a girl a 14 year old girl who
says on 100 occasions or more
she went to jeffrey epstein's palm beach
mansion and was sexually abused her
lawyer said on her behalf the conviction
of guillen maxwell is a welcome
confirmation of the veracity of the
charges brought against her on behalf of
the very brave young women whom she
directly participated in abusing on
behalf of the women i have been
privileged to represent over the past
decade i thank the prosecutors of the
u.s attorney's office for the southern
district of new york for their
unwavering dedication to achieving
justice in this case and i express my
confidence in their continued dedication
satisfaction with maxwell's conviction
is tempered by the knowledge that other
co-conspirators have yet to be held
responsible for their involvement in
jeffrey epstein's extraordinary criminal
enterprise
that is an important important point to
note there were other names
mentioned in this trial alongside gulen
maxwell other people who the women
accuse us in this case and in all this
right
so it does seem as though something is
going to happen here it it does seem as
though something is about to take place
and we're we'll stand by for it i want
to say thanks to hey watch this hold my
beer for the twitch prime subscription
and j2 simpso as well very much
appreciate that number 61 and 62. any
day now this is probably going to start
um
would be our guess
looks like someone's coming here
fedex guy okay fedex guy is coming
through everybody he does have one of
those delivery elements he probably just
scanned a package and off he goes
just a fedex guy everybody relax
everybody relax
um a user
named drinklime just sent their first
chat ever in on twitch their message was
trump122
they have already been banned
that's very very quick that was
extremely quick uh that was your one
shot you shot your shot and you were
banned oh speaking of which i should
look at whether there are unban requests
because it's been a while since we've
taken any of these
uh there is actually okay
mid-range hoops wow means i have no
comeback so i'll make you look like the
crazy one not sure why i was banned yeah
i don't even know why this person was
banned either but i will unban them i
don't know
and it says i banned them which is even
funnier
uh
okay that's fine
sometimes it's crazy people are banned
within five seconds of their first
participation in the channel
and it's
just kind of a joke you know just kind
of a joke it's very very strange
uh okay
let me just get to a couple others of
these
stand by here
let's see here
i'm so embarrassed it's still crystal
i apologize so terribly because i've
watched your show i know that this is
timer
and i just left another message so i'm
going to be one of those callers that
did a double call
what i apologize and i'm mortified
anyways what i was saying is this issue
has grown tremendously because it's now
oh
wow all right guys there's a curve
coming up and that's where everyone got
hurt
here
big action
[Music]
one of the wettest we've ever seen from
the standpoint of the water
coverage um
they seem to be chasing jilane maxwell
at this point although i don't even know
which one is her
this is wild
okay so uh i know we got into that very
very quickly actually let's listen back
in i we just okay let's go over here has
been found guilty on five or six counts
in this trial
we heard previously from
a journalist who uh spoke to galey
maxwell in the past few hours via her
do you want to do it
and
from her we glean that the family
fully the camera is like on the ground
to be acquitted so uh this verdict of
the verdicts that have come in the five
guilty verdicts
are a complete shock to the family this
evening
while we wait for them to come forward
okay so very clearly this is gonna
happen and speak now too
let's see
it's all crazy
um do you want to take my card you said
we're going to be recently releasing a
video free ap
this is what we saw before
and the camera goes so uh it does look
like uh the photographers there uh
really we're walking with
uh family members okay so this seems to
be the most live feed that we have right
now i don't even know who we're gonna
hear from
um
those were her sisters okay i was going
to say none of them actually look like a
lawyer representing jeffrey epstein's
victims lisa bloom oh that's gloria
allred's daughter i believe
but we are so
appreciative of what they did and the
courage that they showed and she is now
convicted sex trafficker elaine maxwell
brought to justice for what she did she
had 60 years of freedom walking this
earth may she never have another day of
freedom again we hope she spends the
rest of her life behind bars
it takes an enormous amount of courage
for um women they were girls at the time
to come forward
and
reopen a case like this and give
evidence this is it's a it's a feeding
frenzy
um let me say thank you to monty un and
andrew dale for the twitch prime subs
number 63 and 64. really appreciate you
guys as well as everybody who's
signed up on the website the next
question is who will be speaking is it
the prosecution should we assume that
it's the prosecution
uh
it's just not clear
it's just not clear
but presumably it's going to be
happening soon there's quite a scrum
here as you can see
and i hope they are all walking a little
taller today and feeling the love that
so many people are sending out to them
for the courage and what they showed
because we got some justice today
you've represented several of jeffrey
epstein's victims have you been able to
speak to any of them this evening yes
and they are just delighted they are
thrilled i mean look it's uh you know
it's very sad what elaine maxwell did
and you know we don't uh you know it's
very sad that she's going to spend
probably the rest of her life in prison
but she brought it on herself she did
this i want to emphasize not just one
day not just one week or one month but
year after year after year in this case
there were 10 years of allegations from
the mid-90s to the mid-2000s
she had choice points
every day every month to stop bringing
girls to jeffrey epstein to be sexually
abused and she chose to keep doing it
why the prosecutors said for money
because she lived an incredibly wealthy
and lavish lifestyle with jeffrey
epstein on his ten thousand acre ranch
in new mexico on his private island in
his 50 million dollar home in new york
in the paris apartment she got to have
that life in exchange she brought girls
to him girls whose lives were ruined so
that's what happened that's what the
jury found and we're very pleased that
they did
were you always fully confident that
this would be the result that it would
be such a unanimous verdict i know that
that trials in federal trials uh
verdicts have to be unanimous but five
of the six counts
uh no i was not confident this was what
was going to happen i believe that this
was the most likely outcome that this
was the just and fair outcome i was in
the courthouse for the whole first week
and saw the testimony and followed it
very closely after that i believed this
was the only correct outcome but you
never know when a you know trial happens
i tried many cases myself sometimes they
end the right way sometimes there's a
mistrial and as the deliberate what a
situation quite frankly i want to say
thanks to catherine krieger catherine
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code obama obama and his new
member number 65. thank you catherine i
really appreciate that
uh so so much
um it looks like
this will probably happen soon although
we really don't know
i am gonna see i'm told that there's
actually some video
might be happening now hold on let's see
here
people are coming out
the u.s attorney has released a recorded
video
you guys remember this
maxwell is in prison and so a lot of
people want to know if she's going to
turn in powerful people and i know
you've talked in the past about prince
andrew and you've criticized bill
clinton's behavior i'm wondering do you
feel that she's going to turn in
powerful men how do you see that working
out i don't know i haven't really been
following it too much i just wish her
well frankly yeah
cool
uh i've met her numerous times over the
years especially since i lived in palm
beach and i guess they lived in palm
beach
but i wish her well
whatever it is uh i don't know the
situation with prince andrew just don't
know not aware of it there you go so
that was uh
that was donald trump some period of
time ago as many of you
no doubt remember
uh getting very chaotic in new york city
at this point very very chaotic and uh
quite literally almost anything might
happen here it's not
it's not exactly clear what we are to
expect other super chats that are coming
in larry quarterwith says hey david are
you excited about the james webb
telescope one small step for society one
giant leap and universal perspective for
mankind i am excited about the james
webb telescope very much so
very very much so
sean says this is a sideshow when does
trump face charges for allegedly doing
the exact same thing it's what what can
you prove
what can you prove as many of you know
um super chats are not on the screen
but they are
coming in
jody says david will you be imbibing
during the new year's eve stream i don't
know what the rules are on that
i don't know the rules on
youtube twitch
and facebook
when it comes to that and we want to be
in full compliance with everything
failed streamer now mod has just
subscribed
via twitch prime that's okay
we're glad to have you here as a viewer
even if you failed as a streamer it's
not a problem
um
really really not a problem in any way
uh
let's see mention that she will get time
received as well
she's going to get time served
one day for one day for every day she
served you know having been denied bail
that's point one point two parole
has been abolished for a long time in
federal court um and the only adjustment
you really get
but there's a continuing point i'm gonna
make the only real adjustment you get
amounts to 15 percent for good time
credit 15
so
on a 10 year sentence it doesn't matter
eight and a half years there's no real
parole after one third as there had been
years ago however and this is important
in the pandemic environment um there are
some situations
where the bureau of prisons has a little
bit more leeway for certain early
release type situations there are
complicated provisions about early
release to community
you know confinement and home detention
so again i can't give you an exact
figure until i crunch it out a little
more but she's facing as i said 10 to 12
years 85 you know 10 to 15 years 85 of
that in and then the footnote of
coronavirus
exceptions and some type of release
exception to a community confinement or
home detention uh but again in my
experience before the pandemic primarily
um you were doing 85 of the amount of
time and then of course once sentence is
pronounced they will appeal and i forgot
to mention and i mentioned it to you
yeah you know there's a lot of headlines
like drudge has a headline now that says
faces 65 years in prison
i'm not actually hearing any legal
experts say there's even any chance that
she gets that everybody's talking about
this 10 to 12 10 to 15 or whatever there
is a report that quite literally right
now
um maxwell met
with a
an abc reporter in the courtroom which
raises questions about you know whether
they're
planning
something is some kind of
pr type move
um
but we don't really know much about it
at this point in time we're just going
to have to wait and see
uh as we continue to stand by here
andrew are there any other elements that
that you might be aware of
uh
well listen there were a lot of people
around jeffrey epstein and elaine
maxwell there were a lot of celebrity
names that were mentioned in the trial i
want to emphasize they were not accused
of sexual abuse in the trial but names
like donald trump and bill clinton and
the uh actor kevin spacey and the actor
chris tucker um
so uh
the senator john glenn and former
astronaut uh john glenn so a lot of uh
prominent people even the pope there was
a picture of elaine and jeffrey with the
pope uh so they certainly traveled in
circle the highest circles of you know
big names and the girls
now women testified that they were
intimidated because of that again we
don't know if any of these others knew
or were participants but if they were
they should be very concerned
wow we hear tonight that the family um
via a third-party journalist who was
communicating with gale maxwell through
a lawyer that the family were fully
expecting her to be acquitted and will
more than likely be pushing for appeals
all right so it looks like things are
finally happening here
uh
let's see
what's going
on uh family i'm sure it's very
difficult to have your sister be
convicted of sex trafficking
uh and you know i'm sure that's very
hard on the family but i have news for
them uh the likelihood of this getting
reversed this just seems like someone
leaving that's all did an excellent job
you have to find an error in the judge's
ruling and she has been very careful in
her rulings in fact this judge is so
good that she has just been elevated to
the appellate court here from the trial
court which is a very prestigious uh
kind of promotion for judges
so i don't think that's a concern i just
won two appeals uh in sexual harassment
and sexual assault cases in california
we won at trial the other side appealed
they have that right we fought and we
won uh this this week and about a month
ago two appeals it's very hard to win
appeals you have to show a very
significant error and you know they can
hope for that but i just don't think
it's going to happen
uh lisa just sum up for us again what
these verdicts mean to the the victims
um okay yeah so we've heard that a bunch
of times now
it
i mean
it seems as though we're getting closer
to the press conference
uh it's hard to understand exactly what
is going on i am the first to admit that
um
and we still don't even know who we're
gonna hear from
we just know very very little very very
little it's it's really wild
hi david so my name is ryan i'm from
north carolina i was wondering if you
were going to cover anything on this
weekend the group the patriot front
went to
washington dc and they're absolutely nut
job um i guess
protest
but i believe that's the same group uh
that got kicked out of or we're not
really kicked out of but
yeah we we covered that i i understand
uh we did cover that
um
let's see i guess so a couple things i
guess a coveted positive person went to
a rally or some something let's see what
this is
[Applause]
oh my god
the hell i have it too
[Applause]
oh my god
what on earth is happening on this
planet
what on earth is happening on this
planet
i had a couple others bookmarked
let me see here
okay here's an anti-massacre freaking
out like as if they don't understand
that these have been the rules for years
now
these are more sad than anything else
it's a mandate it's not a law it's like
i'm so bored with these people not true
you can't discriminate against these
dogs
you can't discriminate against if you
say you gotta wear a shirt is it
discrimination i mean come on guys
for you too
because you're gonna let the [ __ ]
government take your [ __ ] right away
are you crazy
don't let them dictate your [ __ ] life
bro stand up stand up and learn to
[ __ ] lose your freedom your liam dog
your freedom
stand here for your freedom that's gonna
be a no from me
stand up dog your freedom that's all i'm
saying stand up for your freedom all
right we're [ __ ] americans man we
don't need to be under this territical
government bro we don't didn't say
pterodactyl
[Music]
united government of america the
greatest country in the [ __ ] world
that stands up for freedom but then you
can't
as a
person of humanity though you cannot you
cannot enforce these erratic laws well
because it's hurting everybody
it's hurting businesses it's hurting
lying it's hurting the elders bro you
think that [ __ ] is right
they're sitting right do you think it's
right to get up in the security guard's
face
these people
it's um
yeah i don't even know what to make of
it i mean it's just
if at this point they either won't
accept or don't understand the rules
what can you do you know what can you do
um
jersey mike's is that like subway i
guess there was a freak out at a jersey
mike's
yes
go get the [ __ ] out don't want to do
stuff
it's not a law
oh that is so it's like painfully stupid
we just want to get our food
oh wow she was arrested
oh my god they put her in cuffs
man look at that
wow well that's something huh
um
we did the yeah with that one we did
i guess a guy tried to wear underwear as
a face mask on a united flight he was
just thrown out
uh let me see if there's video of that
yeah let's check this one out
count on nbc2 news at 11. i don't wear
them asking the airport at all
at all
tsa makes you do it to get through tsa
but the second i get
my bin and i put my belt back on it's
off
instead of a mask this cape coral man
wears a bright red thong on airplanes
thank you for watching nbc2 wow what a
hero really standing what what a defiant
and principled protest huh i'm peter
bush adam jenny says wait a second oh oh
this guy's name is peter bush imagine if
the guy wearing the thong on his face
was named peter bush i mean that would
i would probably have to cancel my show
at that point in time he's done this
almost two dozen times throughout the
pandemic but this time it didn't fly
with a crew in fort lauderdale nbc 2
sarah metz is talking to the man who
says he is making history
he made history
yes historically stupid a cape coral man
was spotted on a united airlines flight
masking up but not with one of these he
actually was wearing underwear on his
face this is adam jenny
which i replied it's a mask doing its
job wearing his statement piece a bright
red thong i think the best way to
illustrate absurdity yes is with
absurdity
yes yes
says he's worn underwear as a mask since
the beginning of the pandemic every
single flight has been met with
different
different reactions from the fight crew
and this time they weren't having it i
am banned from flying united so so much
for the customer is always right
oh yeah no i don't that that customer is
always right is a very very dumb idea
got kicked off the flight but what
happened after is what really surprised
him people started following
just filing off the plane
maybe a dozen something like that it
happened after this guy questioned why
jenny got removed then he says others
followed his lead good get him off the
plane i would be ch i would be clapping
for the people leaving if i was on this
plane everything
great let's get fewer people on here get
them all out of here it's nonsense it's
all nonsense
kobe doesn't know that we're at cruising
altitude
it's stupid the whole thing is theater
even as covid cases start to climb again
and hospitals fill up wow that's that's
really that's really something huh
what a wild situation
wild
um
let me see if there were any others
oh i guess a woman melted down over a
kid wearing a mask oof
whenever kids are involved it's like
extra weaponized
because his mask is down he knows when
to
your son doesn't have the mental
capacity to know whether because he
can't breathe
this is the epitome of a bad parent
get out of my face babe you too yeah
don't you don't walk up to me you don't
want to mess with me
okay artemis come here you want to get
away artemis what for me
oh it's a dog okay i can't just be kind
to each other first yeah i was walking
by because that child is so young
so many times i just want to let you
know can we just be kind to each other i
agree can we just do that peace man
peaceman is a typical character in these
confrontations it's really really common
that someone will appear
and urge peace
uh that it's it's a
very very well well-known character in
these sort of altercations i guess we
would call them interesting to see him
show up there i want to say thanks to
jen here for gifting a subscription on
twitch that gift is number 67 67.
um everybody just be kind and relax and
so on and so forth uh all all very very
important to talk about the bravery of
these victims i wish i could find better
words to express it
it just takes unbelievable courage i
mean i just ask everyone to think about
it bloom's still speaking there
reporters like yourself maybe the judge
had thought that you know this could
have been
a deadlock or a hung jury were there any
motions for mistrials along the way
because they did deliberate for some
time you know like you said we thought
this might be going uh into new year's
eve new year's day
yeah so since the liberations began
there was no suggestion of a mistrial
except for one exception that was if any
of the jurors got coveted now that
omicron variant is spreading like
wildfire throughout here in new york
city uh and that's exactly why the judge
allison nathan decided to extend the the
deliberation hours over the over the
past couple days the jury hasn't
actually taken advantage of those
extended hours and why judge nathan said
she would also have them meet going into
the holiday they didn't need to do that
they did reach their verdict but that
was the lone fear of a mistrial now of
course the four days five full days of
deliberations and asking for more and
more information did have some people
speculating that perhaps the jury could
result in a hung jury but of course
again we saw that did not happen the
jury did come to conclusion on five of
the six counts with guilty of charging
those five and not guilty for one count
that was the conspiracy to entice jane
that's a pseudonym she was one of the
accusers the first accuser in the in the
indictment all right so they don't seem
to know anything uh drachen mensch
silver flare says via super chat
anti-vaxxers believe in parents right so
much that they would do anything to
prevent other people from parenting
their own children exactly
exactly
other super chats no i think that that's
basically it
um okay
well listen guys this this might be
nothing nothing might be happening and
it's been going on for so long that
we're at the end of my time we've been
waiting for this thing for two hours so
my coverage is going to end here
sentencing will not be today so that is
not what we are waiting for it's
probably just a statement from the
defense or something like that so that's
gonna do it for me uh may see you guys
back here in this calendar year if not
everybody have a great new year but i
may see you again maybe not we'll see
stand by everybody for a lot of
different very very exciting things